é boa tarde a todos
é primeiramente eu fico muito feliz pelo
convite não é por estar aqui
participando e queria compartilhar com
vocês um pouco dessa história né eu
comecei tão novo como vocês podem ver
aqui na foto
em outra foto da minha equipe mais nova
é eu vou começar contando um pouco dessa
história é bem louca eu comecei quando
tinha 11 anos de idade né eu sou morador
da comunidade do morro do adeus uma das
13 que formam hoje o complexo do alemão
e eu comecei a perceber com 11 anos de
idade que a comunidade ela não era
mostrada na grande mídia é pegando a sua
fala que falou disso a comunidade ela
não era mostrada na grande mídia a gente
não se reconhecer a gente não se via ali
né eu comecei a pensar caramba com quem
se pode fazer uma forma de mostrar isso
terá grande pra comunidade é de serem
seus vistas e aí foi quando eu fui dar
uma escola da rede pública e existe um
projeto dentro do grêmio estudantil que
era de rádio e jornal escolar e aí
dentro desses projetos de rádio jornal
escolar é só entrar nos alunos que eram
da dos últimos anos assim é que estavam
terminando e eu não podia entrar porque
tinha 11 anos e aí o pessoal assim não
vai poder entrar só podem anos de 11 e
12 anos também não pode só a partir de
13 e 14 anos
mas eu insisti falei 'não quero
participar eu tenho vontade eu me
interesso pela comunicação eu acho muito
importante e e aí de tanto insistir
insistir fala tá bom pode participar
comecei participando e comecei
observando que o jornal da escola ele
mostrava o que tinha de bom dentro da
escola mas o que há de ruim também
por exemplo quando faltava material
didático quando a quadra da escola
faltava manutenção quando tinha falta de
professores falta de merenda etc
e aí eu comecei a perceber que com o
jornal da escola estava surgindo
resultados quando ele colocava um jornal
levava para a secretaria de educação
os problemas eram solucionados eu falei
caramba porque não tentar fazer isso
dentro da comunidade também criar um
jornal da comunidade e mostrar que a
gente também tem outros problemas
sociais como a grande mídia sempre
mostra o tiroteio a violência todo esse
lado né obscuro da favela mas acaba não
mostrando o que tem de bom dentro da
comunidade nas quais são os projetos
sociais culturais que existem e quais
são os outros problemas que existem na
comunidade que talvez não seja tão
relevante que o resto da sociedade
problemas relacionados a saneamento
básico falta de infraestrutura falta de
energia
falta d'água enfim todos esses outros
problemas e aí e aí o que aconteceu eu
comecei fazendo este jornal na época com
100 exemplares eu não conseguia fazer
mais que isso era cópia certo né eu
ainda era muito criança e aí eu fui
pedindo apoio dos comerciantes locais ou
pedindo apoio da galera da comunidade
alguma coisa pra fazer aquele jornal
acontecer
o jornal foi acontecendo jornal foi
crescendo
outras pessoas vieram com vocês puderam
ver aqui meu primo meu irmão tá ali
também na foto outros vizinhos eo mais
curioso é que assim eu tinha 11 anos
estou aqui sentado no computador ea
galera muito mais nova que eu meu irmão
19 o outro de acesso e outros 16 e todo
mundo criança querendo fazer alguma
coisa querendo participar e era muito
mais uma brincadeira né
a criança está fazendo está dando certo
ea gente começou a ver que mesmo com a
pouca quantidade de exemplares eram 100
no início era uma folha de papel a4
dobrada neco 0 não era muita coisa
começou a perceber que estava dando
resultado a gente estava mostrando e as
autoridades estavam resolvendo os
problemas por exemplo problemas
relacionados ao esgoto a céu aberto nas
ruas que demoravam cerca de seis sete
meses para ser resolvidos por conta dos
pedidos da associação de moradores
começaram a ser resolvidos em menos de
um mês começaram a ser resolvidos em uma
semana e aí essas secretarias que
resolver os problemas entrava em contato
com a gente o nó
o bairro foi solucionado só que o mais
curioso é que quando a gente é criança
nunca
um adulto por trás em outra coisa as
pessoas ligaram mas quem é que vai fazer
nessa matéria são vocês tipo todo mundo
criança e ninguém entendia nada
geralmente quem entra em contato com um
grande veículo de comunicação e tudo
mais e aí a gente foi explicando não mas
nós estamos querendo não está fazendo o
jornal para a comunidade está querendo
de alguma forma mudar que essa realidade
ea gente era pronto atendido e aí
tivemos obviamente muitas dificuldades
principalmente por crianças não só do
poder público mas do próprio comerciante
da comunidade as pessoas também não
acreditava muito no trabalho porque tal
fato de ser criança galera falava sem
raça estão brincando aí alguém está
fazendo algum político que está portais
e vocês estão estão aproveitando de
vocês
a gente começou a colocar fotos nossas
em da equipe do jornal vendo e as
pessoas começaram a dar credibilidade a
acreditar não são eles mesmo estão
fazendo eles estão realmente queira
fazer alguma coisa pela comunidade
e aí o jornal foi crescendo nem foram
passando os anos e um caso que aconteceu
foi o mais marcante na história da voz
da comunidade foi a invasão da polícia
em 2010
nela no complexo do alemão e muito
curioso porque não sei se todo mundo
aqui quem tem twitter aqui tão boa
partida e twitter
na época o twitter no twitter pessoal
tinha cerca de 500 seguidores eram
amigos e professores a galera minha rede
de amigos ele tem 1 500 pessoas e aí
essas pessoas estavam assistindo
televisão tudo o que estava acontecendo
um tiroteio no alemão a invasão da
polícia do mais essas pessoas que
estavam mandando mensagens
ela me perguntava se eu estava bem
estava seguro eu estava em casa como tá
e aí eu respondo a essas pessoas de
repente eu clico aparecem 200 novas
menções aplicar uma conta no twitter
geralmente chega uma nova dimensão duas
novas praças e 200 novas dimensões
ok 209 nações eu fui em tentar ver
alguma quando eu fui começar a ler as
mensagens apareceram 1500 novas
dimensões eo caramba 1501 gestões que é
isso
cada vez mais aparecer menções aí eu fui
atualizando o twitter que tinha 500
seguidores
quando fui ver já tinham cerca de 10 mil
pessoas seguindo e eu não sabia nem que
era o que estava acontecendo isso
faltava responder os meus amigos e aí
foi quando eu fui lá no fundo na
história desde os primeiros tweets lá
ela está me perguntando e fui ver muita
gente famosa estava postando sobre a
invasão do alemão é luciano huck glória
perez regina casé william bom é muitas
personalidades formadores de opinião
estavam pública'
e aconteceu é essas pessoas que estavam
me perguntando se eu estava bem elas
começaram a mandar mensagens para
luciano huck preze na casa consegue ser
menino ele mora no alemão
e aí essas pessoas e personalidades
começaram a me seguir
em seguida repente por william bonner
repente a casa e me seguindo tal era
toda me seguindo e eu não sabia o porquê
eles mandam mensagens perguntando se eu
estava seguro
a glória perez até agora já acertamos a
autora de novelas ela me perguntando se
eu estava seguro se eu não queria ir à
casa dela em copacabana se estou bem ou
ficar dentro de casa mesmo já não vem
pra cá vem pregando um fornecedor tem
que levar todo mundo comunidade local
acabando né
e aí as pessoas todo mundo muito
perguntando o que está acontecendo que
está acontecendo alemão você está bem
está segura e responderão também tô
seguro dentro da minha casa e desfazendo
com calma e dessas pessoas que é
personalidades que começaram a me seguir
eles começaram a recomendar para outras
pessoas
a gente siga esse menino que mora no
alemão se gol e aí de repente as pessoas
começaram a ficar preocupadas com a
minha segurança né porque era um momento
ainda muito delicada porque o tráfego
ainda estava dentro da comunidade ea
polícia estava invadindo eu estava
entrando mas trafegava dentro
então qualquer coisa que pudesse ser um
mal-entendido ali podia acontecer uma
tragédia qualquer
então eu comecei a ficar um pouco
receoso com expostos com que eu ia
publicar tudo mais se falaram por que
você as pessoas começaram a sugerir na
internet porque você não pára de
publicar pelo seu twitter e vai pro
twitter
ronaldo voz da comunidade tá bom aí a
última vez que tinha entrado no twitter
do jornal
são cerca de 180 cento e oitenta
seguidores
aí eu falei assim galera tô saindo do
meu twitter vou pro twitter do voz da
comunidade
quando entrei no twitter do voz da
comunidade já tinham mais de 15 mil
pessoas seguindo e aí quando eu quando
fui entrar no tema dignidade eu fui
reparar que nos trend topics do twitter
os assuntos mais comentados do brasil
estava meu nome voz da comunidade
complexo do alemão um caveirão foi kaká
que está acontecendo no meu nome nos
assuntos mais comentados do país no
twitter
e aí eu fui comecei a narrar pelo
twitter do voz da comunidade comecei a
escrever tudo está acontecendo e chamou
a atenção também da grande mídia
obviamente todo mundo queria saber que
estava acontecendo não estava
acompanhando e aí é a minha família para
me sentar no computador está no celular
ninguém sabe o que vai fazer é instalar
no seu mundo na internet ea minha
família estava sabendo de nada que a
unidade de pessoas seguindo se na
globonews aparece minha cara e aí
aparece a minha cara e fala menino
morador do complexo do alemão está
publicando em tempo real tudo o que
acontece na comunidade a mãe olhou na
minha cara falou que estava lucro ea
vovó todo mundo se esperar foi do
computador desligar a internet não vai
mexer com todo mundo esperaram para o
parar de publicar agora tem que
continuar publicando você vai sair sai
do computador agora e aí a apresentadora
da globo news de repente falar assim
então a gente está acompanhando aqui o
turista pode comunidade parece que é
calmo porque estão postando mais nada é
preciso postar você tem que ver
e aí foi quando eu comecei novamente a
fazer publicações e tudo mais e até
então não imaginava que nada fosse mais
acontecer pra oque aconteceu a invasão
todo mundo ficou conhecendo saber do
twitter e no dia seguinte quando acordei
na verdade foi acordado né
eu tinha um blog é muito interessante
seu blog de 2005 que logo que eu comecei
com o jornal nem quando era criança eu
tenho um blog que tinha o endereço
telefone e monte de dados pessoais lá e
aí nos dias
gente que aconteceu em razão do alemão
já tinha tudo se noticiado ta ai minha
avó me acorda planeta e um monte de
gente no portão pessoal querendo falar
com você eu falei é mas eu não combinei
não liguei para 8 horas da manhã com a
cara toda amassada ainda aí fui no
portão quando cheguei no portão tinham
várias emissoras do brasil e de fora
querendo falar comigo sabe como que foi
o planejamento só que aí de repente
aparece tv al jazira cnn bbc monte de
emissores de fora e exibições do brasil
querendo saber como foi o planejamento
para cobrir a guerra no complexo do
alemão
a lei nós como o rei ficou foi o
planejamento para cobrir e aí
jornalistas não se conformavam é com
aquela situação e todo mundo falando mas
como vocês tinham acesso a essas
informações como vocês publicaram e
assim aconteceram vários momentos que
existiam várias barreiras em que a
polícia não deixava a imprensa subir na
comunidade ainda pelo momento delicado e
aí eu tava lá a partir de dentro das
barreiras porque era da comunidade e
jornalista falou tira ele está fazendo
matéria e por voz à comunidade
mas eu sou morador da comunidade estou
relatando que tá acontecendo e aí todos
os jornais da grande mídia eles
começaram a é falar de várias maneiras
sensacionalistas do que estava
acontecendo no alemão
e aí por exemplo eles mostraram uma cena
lá da entrada da grota da principal onde
estavam várias el as paredes destruídas
mas que o estudo quebradas e aí a
jornalista chegou na frente do espaço
falou o saque foi o caveirão saque
passou o tiroteio aconteceu isso aqui eu
fui comecei a publicar pelo twitter que
não foi isso que ali era as obras do
parque estava acontecendo e àquele lugar
chegue sido quebrado para a construção
de um espaço cultural da comunidade em
geral disse não saber de nada comecei a
publicar isso e aí outros jornais
começaram a falar a voz da comunidade
corrigir grande mídia e começaram a
começar a mandar em vários em vários
jornais e aí tudo bem acontece em razão
do monte
começou a seguir começou a acompanhar
naquele momento todos e quando depois
disso tudo é ter saído na mídia essas
coisas a gente recebeu uma ligação do da
equipe de produção do luciano huck né
que ele tinha
em seguida falou a gente quer contribuir
com vocês que dar uma redação que
conheci esse espaço que vocês têm para o
espaço em si tem na sala da minha vó é o
único espaço que a gente usa para fazer
o jornal
ali na sala mesmo e aí ele conheceu aí
deu uma redação espaços e equipamentos a
gente conseguiu e um outro fato curioso
é que eu nunca antes tinha saído do rio
é pra nenhum lugar
eu nunca tinha viajado nunca tinha
conhecido em outro lugar fora e surgiu a
oportunidade em 2011 no ano seguinte
a ação aconteceu em novembro de 2010
e aí eu fui convidado para palestrar em
são paulo no evento falando sobre a
invasão do complexo do alemão e tudo
mais e depois dessa primeira palestra
surgiram muitas outras oportunidades de
conhecer e viajar pelo brasil afora pelo
mundo também né onde em 2012 eu fui
convidado pela coca cola para ser um dos
brasileiros a carregar a tocha olímpica
de um dos brasileiros a carregar a tocha
olímpica dos jogos olímpicos de londres
era careca é e os brasileiros a carregar
a tocha olímpica em londres
e essa foto ia também muito pequeno nós
ainda quando era jornal pequeno nessas
podem ver ali depois jornal foi
crescendo e aí é e aí eu fui viajando
2012 da tocha olímpica 2013 e fui
convidado pelo consulado americano
estados unidos a criar junto com eles um
intercâmbio de jornalismo comunitário é
um programa de intercâmbio jornalismo
comunitário e aí nós fomos o piloto
fizemos a primeira viagem é no ano
passado nós só eu fui pra universidade
de harvard fazer uma palestra contando
um pouco dessa experiência do trabalho é
em outubro fui gravar uma campanha com a
unilever é na índia e agora no final do
ano passado também em novembro
participei de um simpósio falando da
conectividade de rio e londres das
diferenças e do que tem de ver qual
dessas periferias e aí assim hoje
hoje como está o jornal é muita gente
está se perguntando como está
funcionando hoje até a melissa vem me
acompanhando aqui na beleza está aí a
beleza da voz da comunidade
a gente tem é feito um trabalho de
comunicação comunitária de empoderamento
e dá voz à comunidade os moradores onde
a gente possa cada vez mais mostrar
quais são os problemas sociais o que tem
de cultural o que tende social o que tem
de bom e ruim dentro da comunidade não
acho que isso é o mais importante
essa é parte da equipe da comunidade não
tem uma foto da equipe completa equipe é
bem maior mas é o que a gente faz hoje
né dentro da comunidade não só essa
promoção da comunicação
a gente acaba fazendo entrando em outros
meios né de eventos sociais eventos
culturais de reunir artistas locais com
as disposições faz ações em determinadas
datas comemorativas acaba fazendo
festivais de música festivais culturais
dentro da favela e o nosso papel é nosso
principal objetivo é de realmente
contribuir com essa mudança de dar voz à
comunidade e que as pessoas acreditem
também nas crianças né como poucas
pessoas acreditaram ali no início o
vasco comunidade faz agora em agosto 10
anos né comecei com 11 e e poucas
pessoas acreditavam mas a idéia é
desfazer aquela actividade vamos lá
vamos fazer vai acontecer é sempre fui
muito de falar assim
caraca vamos fazer vai acontecer de
qualquer forma tem que acontecer e aí as
coisas não acontecia então eu fico muito
feliz né portar participando desse
momento de transformação de mudar a
minha vida de outras pessoas de dentro
da comunidade das pessoas hoje que fazem
parte da equipe que contribui
ruim né está sendo é motivando outras
pessoas pelo brasil em outros lugares né
eu estava a mídia veio pra cá ontem eu
estava em belo horizonte fazendo uma
série de palestras também com escolas da
rede pública passe fez um evento de
voluntariado também em que eu contei um
pouco dessa experiência e eu acredito
muito que todos nós podemos fazer uma
transformação social podemos contribuir
muito pra toda essa mudança do mundo
eu acho que tem que começar por dentro
de cada um de nós ok obrigado
obrigado